you take broad city in New York yeah I
think and you tape Eric Andre show here
in LA yeah so do you have a place out
here in LA no I got a rid of place
whatever I'm out here and I'm in May
I've rented this place in the valley and
it was it was a nice house
I had a pool with grotto and it was
getting nice backyard and I'd never been
in a house like that before so I had to
throw a party and the woman that I read
it in from she said I couldn't throw
parties but I said no I got it threw a
party
yeah and I threw one while she was she
was out of town she like kind of stayed
in the guest house but she was out of
town so you said okay she's out of town
I'll throw a party she'll never know
she no no but she had cameras in the
backyard cameras and so she's found out
about the party so I didn't know that
she had cameras so she's calling me she
says how many people are there oh wait
it's live streaming yeah so she's
calling you while the party's Hatcher's
probably why the party's happening and
I'm lying she said how many people were
there like it's a 12 but it really is
about 50 people there
yeah and they will somebody had their
dog and the dog was jumping in the pool
and said what did she say she said get
those people out she was just real angry
about it right right it was a nice party
but then the next day I had somebody
over cleaning up and then she was on the
computer she was on a camera in New York
critiquing the cleanest she's a Hague
have your guide it's clean and put the
garbage can over here and I said you
know I don't want to be critiqued from
New York about the cleaning process yes
and so I checked out of the play she
sucked man I wanted to fight ordered the
fight that night you weren't you weren't
a pay-per-view if I ordered the
pay-per-view to Mayweather fight and
that came on her cable bill and I was
gonna pay it when I checked out but she
kept on bothering me about this money
solder it at 70 bucks for the cable bill
and 60 for something else but I just
paid her in change you got a picture of
this I think this is the change
you were gonna pay it I don't even I
don't even I brought a penny so I'm I'm
a nice petty person yeah
now if that is the last you've heard she
sounds like I'm kind of a pretty strict
no I said the last you heard from her he
texted me about some furniture she
texted me here's a text she sent me
afterwards okay
well you've got to turn the couch back
around to its normal position that will
cost 25 to get someone in here to do
that Maya met back problems they cannot
move that couch and I say it's better
for a you've got a long way to go to be
considered a good comedian no one's even
heard of you Thank You Georgia Hannibal
who out - I don't like her either she's
a real monster yeah yeah well we got the
word out on her I'm gonna rent the place
and just fill it with dogs dogs and
chickens and goats yeah okay
comedy kamisato tour beginning that's
the name tell me help me IIIi I don't
know the word comedy kamisato what does
come asana come asado means a military
attack that occurs at night oh yeah like
a sneak surprise attack
yeah that's a great word yeah so why are
you calling it the comedy kamisato tour
I'm sneaking up on people with my jokes
your humor your humor your cut with your
humor it's gonna be sneak attacks like a
joke that starts out about fresh fresh
juice might turn it to something about
anal sex maybe you were just gonna show
up at restaurants and just start doing a
joke crashing through the window yeah I
love it I love the comedy Commissar how
many kamisato that's great yeah man it's
gonna it's gonna be fun all right this
is a weird life we live and Gear's is
more fun
you